et nous ouvrons ce journal avec et cette
information les premiers délégués du
gouvernement ont été nommés et ont pris
leurs fonctions rappelez vous le 26
octobre dernier
depuis les mureaux été lancée le comité
interministériel pour l'égalité et la
citoyenneté afin de renforcer la
présence de l'état dans les quartiers
les plus en difficulté à trappes pour le
secteur des merisiers et de la plaine de
neauphle c'est olivier van d'art anciens
proviseurs de lycée et ancien inspecteur
d'académie dans le val d'oise qui a
officiellement pris place au sein du
collège gargarine il a pour mission de
favoriser l'éducation
l'accompagnement personnalisé vers
l'emploi la mixité sociale dans le
logement ou encore l'accès aux droits et
aux soins des plus démunis